[Musik]
guten Tag
hallo Jochen mein
Name 2,40 € wie
Quittung
Ars ich bin ein Taxi ich bra nicht
Brinken so der Herrschaften wo soll
eigentlich hingehen nach Düsseldorf
Düsseldorf
[Musik]
raus
gefährliches
halbwiss Jahresvorschau
204 auch also da bin
[Musik]
ich nee war nur Spaß komm steig ein leck
mich doch
[Musik]
geht danke muss muss ne ich glaube heute
kriegen wir noch Regen ich habe ja immer
aufessen ne meine Frau sagte ich bin ein
schnitzelfriedhof wenn man mich fahren
will muss man zweimal tanken jung Frau
Taxi fahren das ist eigentlich wie
Schach ja ich guck zwar auf die Straße
aber hier drin ja da bin ich eigentlich
schon dre vi Straßen im Voraus ich hat
ja schonest hab zu mir gesagt du musst
auch Poli so vorausschauen wie du bist
würd anders in Deutschland
sie strecken kann blind kann Auge
zu sind Sie politisch interessiert 2024
ich kann ih das jah jetzt schon
unterbeten ja hier z.B der
Mehrwertsteuererhöhung ja in der Gastro
da sage ich jetzt schon leute Leute ich
war mit meiner Freundin waren wir
Cheeseburger Essen ich hatte mit POM sie
ohne weil sie gerade denken sie müs aber
ist jetztal bisschen Getränke zu 47 € in
in in Worten 47 und das war noch zu 7%
Frikadelle in Brötchen das ist wenn der
mehrwertsteuererhöung kommt sind wir am
Arsch do hier
ausrechen also 47
€ mal was haben wir Mehrwertsteuer 19%
das muss man sich mal vorstellen einmal
pusten
bitte wenn Sie die mehrweruer von 7 auf
erhöhen da kann ich mir Schnaps eh nicht
mehr leisten so sieht doch
aus ist 50 € kann ich weiterfahren
Polizei du dein Freund und Helfer von
wegen du ja aber auch da sehen sie ja
wieder stresstechnisch da leb ich schon
am Limit ja deshalb von mir aus auch
Daumen hoch dass die da in Sachen dem
Cannabis jetzt hier ab April also
hoffentlich das sollen ja dann
kipferclubs werden Clubs Clubs heißen
sie dann wie Fußballvereine so wie
Herter THC oder SC padabon oder Borussia
dupmund oder wiet a
Bremen ja das muss man Fußballfan sein
ne kommen sie zufällig aus
Norddeutschland ja woher wissen sie das
das hatte ich mir gedacht so am
humorfaktor wissen sie man lernt so
einige Leute
kennen bei eigener Bau sind ja bald bis
zu drei Pflanzen erlaubt der Konsum aber
nur mit mindestens 100 m Abstand zu den
Schule herum darunter fallen auch die
Berufsschulen und D sage ich ihn aber
mit meiner Beobachtung ist ja auch eine
Umstellung für die Schüler weil die
müssen ja jetzt 100 m Abstand haben wenn
sie sich zur Pause einen bauen ne erg
kommen die natürlich auch zu spät lernen
nichts und ja da haben wir den Salat
mein Kleingarten da baue ich jetzt drei
Pflänzchen an davor habe ich ein Straße
dann kommt der frech na Bach dann kommt
die Grundschule bisschen im Schulhof
sind aber nur 87 m dann insgesamt also
13 m zu weg
so hier also hier ist ja quasi der
Frechener Bach ja das ist ja so gesehen
eine natürliche Barriere was soll denn
da passieren das heißt ich darf ohne
Hose am Zaun stehen das ist okay aber
dabei ein Joint rauchen das ist verboten
oder was was heißt hier ich darf nicht
ohne Hose am Zaun stehen aber wenn es
doch mein Grundstück ist weißt du was
ich ziehe jetzt hier die Hose in meinem
Auto aus dann ist mein Gebiet da können
sie ja nichts machen ich bin nichts ich
kann nichts gibt mir eine Uniform wie
Beamtenbeleidigung 120 € haben sie dabei
sie wollen ja zum Flughafen nicht ich
ne ab 2035 dürfen ja nur noch neu Wagen
ohne Verbrennermotor zugelassen
werden muss man sich mal vorstellen ja
das ist mir ja scheißegal hier mein
Oliver hier ne der hat 1,2 Millionen
Kilometer drauf so ne da muss man sich
mal vorstellen und das heißt auch der
hält für die Ewigkeit ich habe genau
gewusst dass diesesbue nichts für dich
ist soll Papa meen Tank Bissen J wieder
Vorwert also ich habe nichts getrunken
was
oh guten Tag hallo einmal zum Ärztehaus
bitte
Arschloch ja also da war jetzt nicht das
war ein Lied Sie wissen was ich meine
stört sie wenn ich das Radio ein
bisschen Anmache alles gut alles gut ist
ja das ist ja so h sehen auch keine
Musik
mehr ja ich war nicht immer Taxifahrer
gewesen ne also ich war ja früher
harrocker gewesen war so richtige Musik
hier
so ja die alten Songs von NAP Dev die
sind einfach einmalig und dann bin ich
dann noch hart und schnitt direkt zu den
kassouter sparzen gekommen weil die sind
auch soundmäßig h die you die
Jungs Mexikaner dich zu lieben Dich
berühren ja schon einige gesagt D ich
eigentlich Schlagerstar werden sollte so
ne ich habe auch schon künstnamen für
mich Hans sie vors mega gewinnspiel vom
Autohaus
rich eurah am 9 juni komm
Europawahlen habe ich jetzt schon keinen
Bock drauf ja was haben die Eurokraten
jemals für
unsemt ja das mit den handykabel
istfallstreffer aber
wenn ich z.B tochlini kaufe ne ich esse
hin und wieder ganz gerne mal tochlini
ja da ist immer zu viel drin für einen
aber immer zu wenig für zwei da ist
immer was übrig ja dagegen tut keiner
was das ist do ein korrupter Haufen ist
das doch leck mich doch am also Sie
wissen was ich meine wissen Sie wann ich
zur Europawahl hingehen würde wenn ich
Holland rauswählen könnte dann würde ich
daingehen und hier der Fußball EM jetzt
im
Juni früher hätte ich mich da ja drauf
gefreut da ich ja hier so fänchen dran
gemacht heute hängt sich doch da keiner
mehr rein für Deutschland die ganzen
Spiele oder Fußball war ja früher auch
noch Profisport gewesen aber heute
machen die das ja eigentlich nur
nebenberuflich ja weil hauptberuflich
sind die alle influencer die sind ja
immer nur noch auf Instagram hier und
gucken hier ich habe mein Lis Vong dem
sein Waschbeutel habe ich in der Hand
weißt du darum jedet den doch nee ne nee
ich mE wenn man Fußball spien will da
muss man den Kopf auch mal vom Handy
hochnehmen ich ich würde das ganz anders
machen ich würde direk die U17
Mannschaft D hinschicken hätte auch noch
den Vorteil dass die ganzen Spiele vor
20 Uhr beendet sein müssen weil die ja
dann schon im Bett sein
müssen genauso würde ich machen oder
oder die die Hockey Nationalmannschaft
die sind nämlich auch letztes Jahr
Weltmeister geworden ne oder oder der
Basketballer am besten schickst du alle
hin die Hockeyspieler mit dem
Hockeyschläger und die bask Basketballer
die sind ja alle so 2,99 m also ich
übertreibbe jetzt nicht die kleineen
Mexikaner sagen dann dirck
Ol kital
ja ich kann jetzt kein Spanisch ja da
muss man Fußballfan sein sonst kann man
da nicht mitreden da stelle ich mich
lieber nackt in den Garten und guck
meine Pflanzen an e sag mal was brauchst
du da so lange h ja oder die
Landtagswahl in den Sachsen Thüringen
und Brandenburg ja alle 3 September da
kann jetzt passieren dass die AFD so gut
abschneidet dass die einzige Alternative
ohne AFD also die einzige Alternative
ohne Alternative dass dafür die anderen
Parteien jetzt miteinander koelieren
müssen also die CDU eventuell mit den
Linken das wird besser als promy Big
Brother das sage ich
ihnen können Sie mir folgen ja ist d ist
besser als promy Big Brother die auf
love Island nackt unter Palmen spielen
ich mir die Politiker aber nackt
vorsteller mus ja und nee ich ich will
nicht einen von diesen lustigen Namen
haben hier mal Kasten Koalition oder
schwarzer Regenbogen das ist einfach nur
Reste wenn Sie mich fragen ne da
ist ein FCK der macht mich die ganze
Zeit schon wsinnig wissen sie so es sind
ja dann noch mehr Wahlen dann ne z.B im
November in den USA beiden gegen Trump
also wahrscheinlich wenn beide nicht
vorher zu Staub verfallen so ne der
beiden der ist do wirklich so alt der
kannte Jesus
persönlich ja aber jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich ich find's ja gut diese
rückgesindnung auf männlicher Erfahrung
Reife guter Mann der wird wie ein Wein
immer älter ist ja so Bo das nervt mich
jetzt schon das Jahr komm raus ich war
jetzt in Kleingarten ich muss was
[Musik]
erledigen
tschüss Tür
[Musik]
zu zentrale hier für den Jochen kommen
bitte ganz wichtig ich hatte gerade
einen Fahrgast der noch nicht den
heutehowkanal abonniert hat das muss man
sich mal vorstellen also bitte an alle
Kollegen weitergeben der wird nicht mehr
befördert ja gut mann mann mann das gibt
Idioten do das gibt es doch gar nicht
unfassbar